كنت نازح في مستشفى كمال عدوان مدني زي
الناس المدنيين اللي انقصف بيوته وقعدوا
في المستشفى قبل بيوم ما يخش الجيش
على على
المستشفى خبط قديفه على الطابق
الاول استشهدوا حوالي اربع خمس اشخاص في
ثاني يوم الساعه 6 السور تبع المستشفى
انهد الدبابات كانت على الشارع على
الباب القناصه اعتلت كل العماير اللي
حوالين
المستشفى صار يقولوا لنا من سن 15 سنه
لحد 70 65 مره يقولوا
طلعوا اطفال مع هم هوايا 15 سنه 16 سنه لا
في كان منا
اختياريه طلعنا حوالي
تقريبا 500
شخص
اه او يمكن اكثر لانه طلعوا كل من كان له
رجلين وبيمشي وطلعنا كلنا شلحنا
وعينا كلها اخذونا على معسكر الجيش انا
تعبان لانه
فطر طبعا انا لما اخذوني
انا شاب رياضي بحب الرياضه بحب امارس
الرياضه شاب في
حالي خر جمعتي مع نفسي متزوج وعندي
اطفالي كان في لي حادث في شهر سته اللي
قبل
الحرب من اثر يعني الرياضه كنت عندي ثلاث
قسور كان في الطرق ركبت لهم
ابلاتين وعندي كان شعر في
الجمجمه كان في عندي مشاكل يعني في
راسي فلما انسحبنا الجيش وشلحني اوعيه صرت
اقول له انه انا ما بنفعش تلوي ايدي من
ورا وتربطهم ربطوني من ورا وغم
عيني ويخبط ني بضربه
ضربتين
[موسيقى]
ثلاث اقول له انا عندي مشاكل فيرا ومركب
بلاتين
يا يا
خيال يقول لي وين
البلاتين يحكي عربي خبطني على البلاتين من
ورا لما طلعلي البلاتين من رقبتي انا فقدت
الاحساس
بايدي اخذوني حمل اللي يخبط في على راسي
وعلى وجهي
كفوف نمرون بالنمر بالارقام
سحبوني على
الشحن حسست حوالي فكرت انه خلص يعني مرحله
الاعدام طلع المشوار طويل خذونا
بالشحن و كنا مغميين ومعصب طبعا ادينا ورا
ظهورنا
نقلونا على ما
اعتقد باتجاه الشمال احنا بقينا الناج
ربنا لانه لله الامر من قبل وم بعد
ا